we welcome to the program Lee Drutman, who's
the author of the book Breaking the Two Party
Doom Loop The Case for Multiparty Democracy
in America, also co-host of the podcast Politics
in Question and a senior fellow in the political
reform program at New America. And by the
way, he I was hoping to surprise him with
this, but he was told guest number 1000 on
The David Pakman Show unique guest. Now, some
guests have appeared many times, but we're
saying not interview one thousand li, but
guest one thousand, which I feel like is a
more precise metric.
Yes, and it's important to have precision
in your mission or else or else you miss measure
and you lead to erroneous conclusions.
Right. And and so I guess maybe we'll apply
that to to our first topic, which is in assessing
the the two party doom loop that we have,
as you call it. Do you have a sense of how
to measure whether the Republican and Democratic
Party right now on policy are closer or further
apart than they've been historically?
Well, I think they are not super close together.
But I mean, actually, this is something that
scholars of democracy around the world do
try to measure.
And, you know, compared to a lot of other
countries which just have a broader spectrum
of parties because they have multiple parties,
Democratic Party and the Republican Party
are not super far apart on policy.
You know, it's there's actually probably more
in common in a lot of policy areas.
What they are divided on is geography and
identity and culture. And there's a real sense
that, you know, Democrats and Republicans
feel like the other party represents a very
different and each of them extreme version
of what America ought to be. And so the real
divide is more about social polarization than
I think it is about policy polarization.
Over the last couple of years, we've seen
on the one hand, this idea that Trump ism
is something different from what the Republican
Party has been for the last decade or 15 years
or so, or maybe in the post Reagan era, we
could even say over the last 30 years. And
yet at the same time, we have actually seen
Republicans by and large, get behind Donald
Trump with rare exceptions. So can what's
your sense of whether the Republican Party
is fractured at this time? Well.
I mean, American parties are always fractured
because they're these big tent parties in
a sense, they're trying to represent half
of the country. So, yeah, they're I think
are a few different visions of what the Republican
Party ought to be within the Republican Party.
And, you know, Donald Trump is sort of the
vessel for at least two of those visions and
organizes the Republican Party, not around
a positive vision of what Republicans ought
to stand for, but as a combative force, fighting
the Democrats, controlling the Libs. I mean,
that's the the motivating force of the Republican
Party right now is preventing Democrats from
being in power. It's, you know, very much
a sense of negative partizanship. And when
you ask a lot of Republicans what they like
about Donald Trump, they like that he's a
fighter. All right. I mean, it's not that
they like his particular policies. They like
that he's fighting for them. And I think that
is the way that he holds a party together
that I think if they actually had to have
a disagreement or had had to have a debate
on policy, you'd actually find much more diversity
in the party.
It's before we move on to how we might break
this two party system that we have it, it
seems to me as someone who's on the left,
that a fractured Republican Party is is good
for the left. And when I look at what's happening
in Georgia, if you have some Republicans who
are saying we've got to vote and then others
who are saying, hey, the whole thing is rigged,
maybe just boycott it and stay home. And Trump's
going after the the governor and secretary
of state of Georgia, that type of chaos seems
like it would be good for the left. What's
your sense of that?
I mean, it's good, I'm not sure if it's good
for I mean, maybe, maybe not.
I mean, I think one of the challenges is that
what you know, unless there's like a real
genuine split in the party in which, you know,
the the the party actually breaks apart, a
lot of folks are going to decide, well, you
know, I don't love I think I think this has
been kind of a a through line.
You know, there's a lot of folks on the right
who say, well, you know, Trump is kind of
boorish and I don't like his tweeting and
maybe he shouldn't have done this, but I can't
vote for the Democrats. So I guess I have
to vote for the Republicans and, you know,
hope that eventually this this does dies out.
You know, I mean, I think I don't think so
much as what, you know, I mean, I consider
myself on the left, but I think more about
what's good for the country and what's good
for the continuation of our democracy. And,
you know, I think having a fractured and chaotic
party that can only be unified by an authoritarian
cult of personality cult leader, which I guess
is probably the best description of Donald
Trump, is very dangerous, that you need a
center right or a right party that believes
in basic idea that you have free and fair
elections and those elections are legitimate.
And, you know, we don't have that right now.
And that is that is the true danger. So, I
mean, maybe there'll be some fracture and
there'll be a a faction of the party that
says, look, you know, whatever disagreements
we have with the left, we agree that we have
to have a democracy with free and fair elections.
And that is the cornerstone of our system.
And, you know, we can argue about tax policy
later. But the first thing we have to agree
on is that, you know, you have elections that
are legitimate.
So what would have to change for the U.S.
to go more in the direction of of having at
least one more party that's regularly viable?
A few of the things I've talked to my audience
about include changing how politics is financed
would probably be near the top of the list,
also potentially changing first past the post
voting at least within states, so that the
spoiler effect, which he keeps a lot of people
from going in the direction of an alternative
to Democrats and Republicans would probably
be be near the top of the list. Do you agree
with these two items? What other items would
you add?
Yeah, I mean, I certainly support campaign
finance reform, but I think that the real
reason why we have just two parties is because
we have a voting system first past the post
plurality single winner elections in which
votes for third parties, new parties, minor
parties are effectively wasted. And so all
the all the energy and focus goes into the
top two parties and it's very hard for new
parties to emerge. Now, the U.S. is an outlier
in this respect. I mean, most of the world's
democracies have proportional voting systems
that do not punish smaller parties. Most democracies
around the world are proportional multiparty
democracies. And there are certainly a range
of of rules that you can structure the party
competition. I think a healthy number of parties
is probably between four and six. I'm not
suggesting that we become Israel and have
like, you know, 13 parties and Israelis is
a very extreme form of proportional representation
that that neither I nor most people who study
electoral systems would recommend. You know,
I think the model here should be something
more like Ireland, which uses multimember
districts, typically three to five member
districts with a right choice voting. So they
just call it proportional representation in
another model. And this might work better
for the Senate, although it would require
a constitutional amendment is what New Zealand
does, which is they people elect representatives
for for their legislative district and then
they have a second party list vote in which
they vote for a party. And the parties get
effectively compensatory seats in the legislature
based on how well they do on the party list,
so that it ensures that if you have fifty
three percent of people want Democrats, Democrats
have 53 percent of the seats, not just how
how Democrats and Republicans happen to shake
out in particular states or districts that
build consensus to even change that system.
Right. Because, I mean, even the conversation
about electoral vote versus popular vote to
pick the president, one party has benefited
from the fact that we have an electoral college
and one party has lost out on on multiple
presidents in the White House as a result
of that. So there's a large portion of those
in power who have no incentive to change that
system. How do you how do we get over that
hump?
There are some people in power who want to
maintain the status quo, but I would say a
few things, you know, one, if you talk to
most people in power, elected Democrats, elected
Republicans, you know, a lot of them feel
like things are really broken and they feel
stuck in this system and they feel trapped
in this system. And they don't actually want,
you know, in their preferred world, they wouldn't
just be foot soldiers in an endless partizan
trench warfare where they keep digging deeper
and deeper holes.
Now, you know, I think within the Democratic
Party and within the Republican Party, as
we were discussing, you know, there are different
factions, there are different groups that
feel like they have a vision for how politics
ought to be. And that vision is is suppressed
in this current binary hyper partizan system
in which nothing actually happens because
the parties are kind of deadlocked.
So, I mean, I think there are enough people
in elected office, maybe not the heads of
their parties, but who might say, look, the
system isn't working for us and, you know,
maybe we can try a different system in which
maybe we get to play a different role, perhaps
a better role in actually working out legislative
compromise and trying to trying to solve problems
instead of just fighting each other and endless
messaging wars in which all this money is
wasted just to fight to basically the same
point that we've always been. I mean, for
all the money that has been spent on this
election, it's remarkable how little movement
there was among voters. I mean, it was, you
know, basically the same same outcome as as
2016 and the popular vote with Biden winning
a little more and Biden did a little bit better
and a handful of states in that, you know.
Yes.
In that very, very, very well said. So we've
talked a little bit about the Republican Party.
We've talked about a multiparty possibilities
to talk a little bit as we get down to the
end of our time about the Democratic Party.
There was a modest amount of sort of never
Biden sentiment during the primaries. And
even shortly after Joe Biden, it became clear
Joe Biden would be the Democratic nominee.
But in the end, most Democratic voters did
vote for Joe Biden, even if they would have
preferred someone more progressive. Is the
Democratic Party likely or how likely is it
to fracture in a in a significant way between
the sort of bulk of the party and the progressive
wing?
Well, you know, I mean. I think the fights
will continue.
I mean, I mean, a fracture would be significant
and I think Democrats unified around Biden
because they wanted Trump out of office. Yes.
That it was you know, I mean, if you looked
at polls, it was not a resounding vote of
enthusiasm for Joe Biden as much as it was
a resounding vote of of get Donald Trump out
of office. And now, you know, who knows? I
mean, I think, you know, I think I think the
the progressive left feels, you know, like
it it doesn't have a lot of room to maneuver
given the narrow majorities that Democrats
have in the House.
On the other hand, it gives them more leverage.
But, you know, the threat of Trump winning
in twenty twenty four or somebody Trump like
winning in twenty twenty four. I mean, this
is this is the problem with, ah, you know,
closely fought binary politics is that everybody
is just trying to win the next election.
And so there's all this, you know. Well, you
know, we're not going to discuss ideas, we're
not going to have debates about policy. You
know, we just have to make the Republicans
look bad.
We just have to keep them out of office. And
then we have the luxury of having an actual
discussion over policy because we can't fracture.
And that's just the kind of status that politics
is in. I mean, in order, I mean, politics
has to be dynamic.
There have to be fights and there have to
be disagreements and there has to be uncertainty
and there have to be opportunities to form
new and different coalitions. But we're in
this kind of frozen state in which everybody
feels like they're losing.
Everybody feels like, you know, just one election
and the entire character of America will be
destroyed and, you know, creates this incredible
sense of frustration.
Meanwhile, there are real problems that we
have to deal with climate. I think being to
me the most important and existential, you
know, that we're just ignoring.
Yeah, I am less concerned, as you're pointing
out, the fact that there would be disagreement
within or between parties, but even within
we're kind of talking about here, I'm less
concerned by that. And that's less of a sign
that that that of a problem in the Democratic
Party. For me, the concern comes if there
is a wing that is representing a significant
number of Americans, that seems to never actually
get anything for those constituents that that
are in line with them. That is more of a concern
for me than the fact that there are disagreements
or even factions, because that actually seems
completely natural and natural and healthy
the way you're pointing out.
Yeah, it is natural and healthy. And, you
know, if we were in a in a multi-party system,
you know, there would be a social Democratic
Party and there would be, you know, moderate
centrist Democrats, no center left party.
And then those parties could go directly to
the voters rather than having to compete in
different primaries.
And, you know, we we know what the popularity
of their different programs were.
And then those would be bargaining chips as
they worked out legislative solutions. Instead,
there's a sense that, you know, Democrats
have to hold together. They have to win that
majority, which means they have to win those,
you know, slightly conservative suburban districts,
which means they can't do anything to progressive.
And that's just the way the math works.
Yeah, no question about it. We've been speaking
with Lee Drutman, who's author of Breaking
the Two Party Doom Loop The Case for Multiparty
Democracy in American in America.. He also
co-hosts the podcast Politics in Question
and is a senior fellow in the political reform
program at New America. Ali, I really appreciate
your time today.
Thank you, David. This was this was a great
conversation. And, you know, folks, you know,
think about this is a serious solution to
our gridlocked and broken politics.